[Music]
as astronomers we're very fortunate that
um it has huge public appeals and
secondly it's easy to understand the
questions that we're addressing where
did the universe come from what's its
fate you know where did is there life
elsewhere in the universe you know what
is a black hole so the questions we're
asking now are really quite simple when
did Cosmic Dawn occur you know was it a
gradual slow event or was it dramatic
you know did did the whole universe
which on in Starlights sort of in a in a
short period and perhaps the most
intriguing question given James Webb is
working so well
do we have the capability to recognize
a first generation
Stellar system that is an object that's
pristine chemically pristine that is
just emerging from Darkness any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to an exciting episode
a cosmic episode going back to the very
dawn of the universe featuring a
renowned cosmologist and professor of
astrophysics that's Professor Richard
Ellis who is at the in the faculty of
maths and Sciences at University College
London where I've been for a little bit
and he is known the worldwide for his
contributions to our understanding of
the universe we're using observational
cosmological techniques telescopes
computers a massive brain that he
possesses and that's with observations
and a lot of times we've had on past
guests on the show such as Neil deGrasse
Tyson and Martin Reese and others this
is very different he is actually a user
of these great enormous instruments
including the eso's VLT the twin Keck
telescopes the Atacama Alma instrument
and many others and and of course we'll
talk about the latest and greatest
developments with Webb and how bubble
and so forth but he is really uh on this
podcast today because of a connection
that I had to him through my colleague
at the University of California up the
road in Los Angeles and that's uh
Michael Rich who's kind enough to put me
in touch and Michael I think has the
distinction Richard connect correct me
if I'm wrong but I think he was Neil
deGrasse Tyson's thesis advisor that's
right yes he was in Columbia University
in Columbia that's right so there's a
connection to past guest uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson and he is the reason so
thank you Michael I hope you're watching
this and enjoying this thank you for
your generous introduction uh we have
the opportunity to talk about this
phenomenal new book that is I don't know
how you did it but it's a page Turner
it's something that's enjoyable to read
for professionals and for Lay people
alike and you've just come off a mini
book tour of Los Angeles the highlights
of uh hobnobbing with celebrities and
and benefactors at Caltech and elsewhere
and that has to do with your past where
you used to be a member a teaching staff
and we cross paths briefly but neither
one of us remembers the other
unfortunately but this book is is really
just just a delight and uh you're to be
congratulated sir I want to start as I
do with all my esteemed guests who have
done the heroic uh effort of writing a
book a popular level book that's
understandable by anybody with a
curiosity and Imagination and that's I
like to judge books by their covers
you're never supposed to do it but I'm
gonna do it because what else dear God
can we say about a book until we've
actually read it as I have in multiple
formats so Richard take us through help
us judge the book by its cover explain
the title The subtitle and the
temperature image yes sir take it right
let's go okay so the the title is when
galaxies were born so the idea is that
we would probe the universe back in time
and see whether we could actually
directly observe of the first galaxies
emerging from darkness that moment is
called Cosmic Dawn and that's the
subtitle of the book The Quest for
Cosmic Dawn and it's the story of uh
really an adventure scientific Adventure
that has taken about 50 years and
Beginning to Look Back further and
further back in time now the cover
picture itself is the observatory on
Mauna Kea the top of uh the big island
of Hawaii which is the best Northern
Hemisphere site in the world for optical
astronomy and it shows the array of the
quintack telescopes which I used when I
was at Caltech uh the Japanese Subaru
telescope and it's a photograph taken
actually
um not not at dawn but at sunset or just
uh Before Sunset but the sky behind it
gives the impression of the dawn of
light in the universe and there's a big
beautiful picture of a galaxy on the top
just to make it looked very beautiful so
it took some effort to convince
Princeton University press they came up
with a number of covers but I insisted
it had to have an observatory
uh in the foreground so that everybody
knew this is to do with observational
astronomy and I think it's a striking
cover you know I I'm not afraid of
people going into a bookstore and
judging a book by its cover so I spent
quite some time assembling this
photography obviously it's a montage of
an actual photograph taken from Mauna
Kea uh with galaxies in in the
background that's right and the book
covers so much and and what I love about
it in particular is there's so much uh
care and attention paid to observers and
what observers have done and the quest
is is sort of underpinned by the
advances in technology ranging not since
you know the beginning of time or since
uh this guy over here which I always
have a a finger puppet handy of my of my
hero the very first observational
astronomer in history to use a telescope
and that's I don't know if you recognize
this guy it's Galileo Galilee yeah right
right and he said something very
interesting Richard in cedarius nunchus
Starry Messenger he said the following
he said the these sites which with
viewed but with the aid of this
perspiculum tube namely the telescope
the Spyglass as it was known uh are here
to four revealed in such great detail
that the wordy arguments of philosophers
are utterly destroyed meaning that
people would speculate about well was
the Milky Way comprised of stars were
the Pleiades purely Stars uh were there
was the moon completely crystalline and
smooth talk about what a telescope well
actually I want to ask you a first
question what was your first experience
like when you look through a telescope
well I made my own telescope as a child
and the first thing I looked at was
Jupiter and its moons
um but what struck me actually first of
all was the colors of stars now if you
walk down the street
um you know and look up at the night sky
you can see the stars and if you're very
perceptive you'll see that the stars
have colors some of them are Blues some
of them are red and that became much
more uh evident when I
um I had my own telescope but it was a
very modest telescope four inches I was
living in North Wales where it rains all
the time so you know it wasn't
um an enjoyable time to go out observing
but I was fascinated and I was so hooked
on astronomy
I couldn't wait till it got dark you
know in the afternoon I was thinking
what time's sunset today you know and uh
I can take my little telescope out so
the colors of stars relate to their
temperatures and you know it's that
connection where you make an observation
and it puzzles you you know a star
shines why aren't they all the same and
the answer is some of them are massive
some of them are not less massive the
massive ones are forming are shining
very brightly and they're hotter and
that leads to Bluer colors the cooler
ones are less massive and they shine in
in red light so you know it you know as
a 12 year old on observation like that
leads to a question well what does
illness mean and so that links back uh
very much to your Galileo quote I think
yeah and I always like to point out that
when you think about scientific
exploration and learning and education
you cannot feel what it was like for
your Countryman Peter Hig
to know that the Higgs boson had been
discovered he couldn't look into the
Higgs uh into the LHC and detect it nor
could anybody because it took years to
compile the data the data are not
particularly viscerally inspiring but
with a telescope you can reproduce with
a tiny little telescope like this one uh
which I always keep with me at all times
uh you can see the exact same sites that
Galileo saw no matter where you are on
earth no matter what time of year you're
looking and even in the midst of a big
city uh you can see the same sites but
more than that Richard you can feel what
Galileo felt and no other scientific
exploration is that possible you can't
do it even with the microscope but
everybody can viscerally appreciate the
thrill of Discovery and I think that is
a unique aspect of astronomy that we
don't quite frankly take enough
advantage of because we have this
wonderful ability to convince people of
the joys of astronomy so anyway
all right well let me just comment you
know we're unfortunate as astronomers
we're very fortunate that um it has huge
public appeals and secondly it's easy to
understand the questions that we're
addressing where did the universe come
from what's its fate you know where did
is there life elsewhere in the universe
you know what is a black hole and you
know compare that with Biology where
there's a lot of jargon uh that you have
to learn in order to understand what a
biologist is doing in his or her
research so recently there was a survey
of um uh people in professional careers
Engineers mathematicians economists or
you know doctors and they asked them
when when they were young when they were
children what inspired them uh to go
along the careers they have and in many
cases it was astronomy you know because
it's such an accessible uh science and
the curiosity is very popular and
wide-ranging in the community
that's right and we need to really be
aware of that and the biggest picture
you and I were chatting briefly before I
started recording about the dearth of
books other than cosmology astronomy or
particle physics and so forth and uh
I've had on some great guests and we'll
have on many more from you know that
have written books about condensed
matter physics or biophysics and things
like that a lot of people have talked
about the Consciousness in the brain
from a quantum mechanical perspective
including your countrymen sir Roger
Penrose many times on this podcast uh
and it's so delightful but nothing
really captivates the mind like
astronomy because we're all born with
two refracting telescopes embedded in
our skulls and as we get older we can
observe directly yeah right that's right
so and even the cover you know image we
can see in the most distant object
visible to the naked eyes the Andromeda
galaxy and that Galaxy uh has light that
uh left it when Lucy was walking about
the uh Serengeti plane so these things
just Boggle the mind and then of course
in the later or you know more recent
times people have speculated about the
existence of other universes which which
uh you know can come into play as we as
we learn more and more about the physics
of the extreme early Universe perhaps
through inflation so Richard you've been
kind enough to um to provide a set of
slides which we will overlay and you
presented these in a public level talk
and I don't want people Richard is one
of the most distinguished professors on
Earth and and has the medals and so
forth to prove it but uh this talk
you're going to present is suitable for
the public so do not be intimidated I
love to bring the most advanced
knowledge to my audience because they're
the brightest Minds in the known
Multiverse but Richard is going to
present a set of slides that he's
prepared that Loosely traced The Arc of
this book and then at the end you and I
will conclude with some discussions
about the future of the Quest for Cosmic
Dawn so please Richard if you wouldn't
mind sharing your screen and uh starting
your PowerPoint discussion this image
here is uh the deepest one of the deep
images that was first taken with this
new telescope the James Webb toast
telescope and it is a truly astonishing
image what you see
firstly is a star in the Milky Way very
very sharp you see a cluster of galaxies
that are these objects in white that are
all at the same physical distance but
you see also these distorted red objects
many of them are arc-like and these are
background galaxies whose light has been
magnified and stretched by the material
in this foreground cluster of galaxies
and this image was presented uh in July
of last year as the first exciting
science image with the hubbles with the
James Webb Space Telescope by President
Biden and you know the advance here is
that these objects are very very distant
and if we look to Great distances in the
universe we look back in time so
astronomers are very special uh in that
they can time travel
um when we look uh deep in the universe
the light has taken such a large
fraction of time of the affection of the
age of the universe to reach us that
we're seeing the universe in the past
and so clearly we have the capability
to time slice the universe if we can
it's determine the distance uh to a
remote Galaxy we can calculate at what
time in history we are observing that
object and by looking at galaxies at
different distances we can recreate
astonishingly the past evolution of the
universe and
um obviously to do this we need a marker
we need some measurement that tells us
how far back in time we're looking and
the key to doing this is the expansion
of the universe now people probably know
that the universe is expanding
but I'm sure you remember Brian it's
incorrect to think of the expansion of
the universe as galaxies moving as
projectiles through pre-existing space
it is actually space itself that is
expanding and so for example when a
light Ray
leaves a Galaxy over here
this blue light Ray travels towards the
Earth the distance is so vast and the
time it takes is so long that by the
time the light Ray reaches us the space
between these two galaxies has been
stretched
and here's the key point the light Ray
itself has been stretched as well and if
we can measure this stretching which we
call the redshift people already heard
of this term the redshift that is the
stretching of the light Ray is actually
the factor by which the universe is
expanded since the light Ray was emitted
so if we have some idea
of the history of the expansion of the
universe then we can convert this
measured redshift into what astronomers
call Look Back Time now this is very
important and very useful concept look
back time is how far back in time we're
looking when we observe a distant object
and
um over the last say 20 years or so
um the partnership between the beautiful
Hubble Space Telescope images
and ground-based telescopes has allowed
us to piece together a sort of
picture book history
of the universe back to when it was
about one to two billion years old
so the universe today we think is 13.8
billion years or so old that's about
three times older than the solar system
or the Earth
and I just for schematic purposes here
I've just shown some beautiful nearby
galaxies this one's what we call an
elliptical as a ball of stars all of the
stars are the same color this is a
spiral galaxy like the Milky Way you can
see it has a nucleus it's got beautiful
spiral arm it's got a little companion
and as we go back in time you can see
galaxies that at uh when the universe
was about 40 percent of its present age
you still see objects that look like
this elliptical you still see galaxies
maybe they're not as elegant as the
spirals that we see today but they do
have a nucleus and a blue disc like
structure that's right but look look at
this when we go to when the universe was
only one to two billion years old
so that's about 10 of its present age
the galaxies are physically small
they're not symmetrical many of them
have multiple components as if they're
coalescing
so over the last 20 years with Hubble
and telescopes like the Keck telescopes
in Hawaii we've got a sort of General
view of the assembly history of galaxies
and my book describes this progress in
some detail but the real uh challenge we
now face and the excitement in the
subject uh is probing even earlier to
when galaxies first emerge from Darkness
so this is obviously a cartoon so time
is running from left to right uh this is
the Big Bang the glow from The Big Bang
we call that the microwave background I
don't have to explain that to you Brian
you're an expert in this area
um as the big bang you know as the
universe expands from The Big Bang uh
the gas cools as the universe expands
and eventually the hydrogen atom forms
for the first time about 370 000 years
after the big bang but the universe is
very dark
um we call this period the Dark Ages
astronomers you know love this word dark
you know because it is miss you all
heard of Dark Matter maybe you've heard
of dark energy this is uh this adds an
air of mystery to the subject that is
very good in fundraising but uh the Dark
Ages here eventually come to an end
because the gas clouds collapse and as
these hydrogen clouds collapse they get
hotter in the center just like a bicycle
tire gets Hearts when you compress the
gas in in pumping it up and eventually
the gas clouds become hot enough in
their cores to ignite nuclear fusion
which is of course how the Sun Shines
and at that moment
the universe is bathed in Starlight For
the First Time
now many people think the Big Bang is
the biggest you know Epoch in the
history of the universe and it's
certainly a very important and
mysterious one that we don't completely
understand but I would argue that Cosmic
Dawn is equally important milestone in
Cosmic history because stars are
producing the elements the chemistry the
chemical elements in the universe at the
time when these first stars form there
is no carbon there's no Oxygen there's
no nitrogen silicon iron all of these
elements that we see around us today
including the material that makes our
bodies the calcium in our bones the iron
in our blood is all synthesized in stars
and that all began at Cosmic Dawn so in
some sense Cosmic Dawn is the beginning
of you and me it's the beginning of the
process that leads to life so
understanding Cosmic Dawn is really
important
now over my career we've probed to
successively Greater distances
look at that once starts in the 1960s
this is a graph of this redshift
if you prefer it's the age of the
universe at which the Galaxy is being
observed and you don't even have to
notice the numbers you can see as a
function of publication date as we had
more powerful telescopes we started
probing galaxies when the universe was
younger and younger and younger
and already since the launch of James
Webb Telescope that's been in just six
months so much progress in understanding
and extending this Frontier that it's
very very exciting
so the questions we're asking now are
really quite simple and that's I think
the beauty of astronomy you know you
don't have to have a PhD to at least
understand what we're trying to do when
did Cosmic Dawn occur
was it a you know was it a gradual slow
event or was it dramatic you know did
did the whole universe switch on in
Starlights sort of in a in a short
period and perhaps the most intriguing
question given James Webb is working so
well
do we have the capability to recognize
a first generation
Stellar system that is an object that's
pristine chemically pristine that is
just emerging from Darkness
now my book you know uh was uh published
uh following the successful launch of
James Webb and it gives a lot of the
history of how we got to this point and
the technology uh that has enabled all
this amazing progress that has got us
back to observing galaxies when the
universe was only a few percent of its
present age
uh the story starts in California with
the mighty Palomar telescope which many
uh listeners may have visited it's a
fabulous place uh my own career began in
Britain and uh for for many years my
telescope was the anglo-australian
telescope which was opened by Prince
Charles now King Charles of course in
Australia Britain then built telescopes
in the Canary Islands then I emigrated
to California and I started using the
tech telescopes in Hawaii as well as
Palomar and as you've said in the
introduction I'm now back in Europe and
there's the European very large
telescope in the Atacama Desert in Chile
but these are ground-based telescopes
um we measure the power of these
telescopes by the size of their mirror
um we of course have space telescopes
too
everybody's heard of Hubble uh by the
way it's still operating it's not being
eclipsed by James schweb it's still
doing great stuff the Spitzer Space
Telescope has finished but it is was an
infrared telescope and it's incent in a
sense its successor is it you know uh
just to interrupt briefly that my
colleague Nick Spitzer is the son of
Lyman Spitzer is that right okay San
Diego yes he's uh that's amazing is he
an astronomer then no he's a brilliant
National Academy member of neuro a
neuroscientist but he has uh shared with
me in many Recollections of his with uh
seeing Einstein back at the institute
for that study with his with his uh with
his renowned father yeah sorry a little
connection to space yeah well that's
very exciting well Lyman Spitzer
features in my book as one of the two
Heroes uh that led to the success of
Hubble Space Telescope that's right so
let me uh let me take you back to
um the 1920s where this amazing man
George Ellery Hale uh who was himself
the distinguished solar astronomer
um he had a nap for raising money
um from wealthy donors for a succession
of what became the world's largest
telescopes the 60-inch and 100 inch on
Mount Wilson just outside Los Angeles
and here the beautiful Palomar
Observatory halfway between Los Angeles
and San Diego
um you know I'm I'm a little romantic
really
um here's a here's a picture from my UNC
encyclopedia from 1958 when I was a
little eight-year-old boy and I would
turn back to this page many times it's a
cut out picture of of a big telescope it
didn't say the name of the telescope but
it clearly is uh the Palomar 200 inch as
you can see from this nice photograph
and little did I know when I was eight
years old uh that one day in California
even that I would move to California but
one day I would become the director of
this telescope shown in this
encyclopedia when I was eight years old
now
Hillary Hale
higher than doing Hubble
and Hubble sadly had a heart attack just
as the 200 inch was coming online
but he began a program
to look back in time this was I mean at
Palomar the whole concept of looking
back in time uh unfolded and as Hubble
uh had this heart attack and died in
1953 he handed the Baton to his disciple
at the Carnegie observatories Alan
sandwich shown here who passed away in
2010 and the idea was to use the 200
inch to measure the history of the
cosmic expansion to use the brightnesses
of galaxies to measure their distance
and to measure their red shifts to tell
us the velocities that they had from the
expansion of the universe and to see
whether the universe was slowing down in
its expansion as people predicted
um now sometimes people think
astronomers are um you know fairly easy
going people but believe me it's a
competitive subject and uh within the
same city in Pasadena at Caltech uh was
a rival to Alan sandwich of Jim Gunn a
younger man who's still with us
fortunately and the two of them battled
it out on this massive telescope they
were doing the same project competing
with one another and and then
Along came a woman uh Beatrice Tinsley a
theorist a New Zealander who visited
Pasadena in 1975 and demonstrated to
both these famous Pioneers Sandage and
gun that you know just as stars evolve
and explode and change their colors and
brightnesses as they grow old
obviously galaxies must do the same so
you cannot estimate the distance to a
Galaxy by its brightness and this was a
huge shift in the subject when I was a
young postdoc this is I just got my PhD
that we really are looking back in time
not to measure the rate at which the
universe is slowing down but to
understand the galaxies themselves and
to look back to their birth and so that
is really uh the theme of the book and
of course I've lived through an amazing
period where technology has made a huge
advance in our capabilities firstly
these Pioneers like Hubble Sandage gun
believe it or not we're using good
old-fashioned photography and
um
and you know it was really slow and hard
work
um now of course we have digital
detectors such as the ones in our mobile
phones and these can be 30 to 40 times
more efficient than the photographic
plate and so at a stroke
um you can imagine having a telescope
that's just 30 to 40 times more powerful
by incorporating a digital detector
um I mentioned that the size of a
telescope uh is its power the diameter
of the mirror 200 inch is five meters
um it was the biggest and most powerful
telescope in the world for 40 years but
eventually it was eclipsed by eight
meter class telescopes and the quick
twin uh 10 meter cut telescopes
and then finally the the the the last
sort of innovation
really
um was what we call multi-object
spectroscopy you see to measure the
redshift of a galaxy and hence its look
back time you need to
um gather the light and Sandage and
Hubble and others were doing this one
Galaxy at a time if you could Multiplex
if you could gather the light as is
shown here in this top panel on the left
here if you could gather the light of
say 50 galaxies at once in the field of
view of the telescope which is this
little square area here with Optical
fibers which is very much like Optical
plumbing and gather the fibers and feed
them into uh a spectrograph then you can
measure the redshifts of 50 galaxies in
the time it takes to measure one a huge
step forward in the subject
initially this was done manually
um this is me over here in the 1980s
plugging in fibers into a brass plate
where the holes have been drilled at the
precise positions of galaxies But
ultimately we used robots to do this and
now this is big business people are
using robots to measure galaxies 5000 at
a time so this was a huge Revolution as
well
now how do you measure how do you select
the galaxies that are the most distant
even if you still have to do the
spectroscopy and there's a very clever
trick which was uh which was first
pioneered by one of my calteens former
Caltech colleagues Chuck steidel and
that is that the Universe has a lot of
hydrogen
uh not just in the stars and in the in
the space in between the stars but even
in the space between galaxies and
hydrogen has a very characteristic
absorption in the ultraviolet
um and it cuts off the light and the
wavelength at which it cuts off the
light is an indication it's an
approximate indication of how far away
the Galaxy is so for example in this
little picture from Palomar you see a
field of galaxies taken in a red filter
you see a field of galaxies taken in a
green filter you see it in the
ultraviolet
but this particular Galaxy circled here
disappears excuse me a minute
um and that's a hint that this object is
very distant and that this absorption by
hydrogen has been shifted so that this
galaxy so-called drops out
here's a little uh a cute movie that
shows you these are all the color
filters on Hubble Space Telescope
there's blue filters green filters
yellow filters orange filters and red
filters and infrared filters and the
energy spectrum of this galaxy moves
through
and you can see the redshift is going up
and up and up and hence the look back
time is increasing and you can see in
the pictures below that as the Galaxy
moves further away from us
it disappears respectively in different
filters so if you can see at which
filter a Galaxy disappears or drops out
then you get an approximate estimate of
the Look Back Time to that Galaxy
so you know my book is
um also about the sociology of observing
um you know young people go to the
telescope
um it's inspirational to observe I mean
it is possible of course to do or do it
over the internet and of course
practically speaking during the pandemic
and if you are short of cash for going
to the telescope then the internet does
offer uh the ability to observe remotely
but I think there's no substitute I'm
really a traditionalist there's no
substitute for
going out of the office and going to the
telescope focusing on the task at hand
and it's inspirational to make a
discovery in real time and so going
through
some of the moments of Joy uh is covered
in the book but of course there are
cloudy nights this is a cloudy night
photograph where you know it's very
depressing this guy on the left here his
thesis is disappearing because he's had
four cloudy nights in a row and um you
know so uh there are ups and downs uh in
observation astronomy just like in any
other scientific discipline
so how far did we look uh with Hubble uh
well there are two ways of going as deep
as possible one is to point Hubble in a
not particularly interesting area of sky
and exposing for a long time and this is
one of those Ultra deep exposures it's
called the Hubble Ultra Deep Field it
was taken by our team where here we are
at the University of Edinburgh this is
me and my Coco investigator Jim Dunlop
and uh the Galaxy's shown um if you can
spot them with these colored squares
with the numbers are the most distant
galaxies in this image this field of
view is about the tenth the diameter of
the full moon
and there are about 3 000 galaxies in
here and Via this color technique that
we just discussed
these um six or seven objects are the
most distant and this particular one we
thought might be at a red shift of 11.9
which would be the most distant object
ever seen with Hubble the other
technique in addition to this sort of
rather mindless just point Hubble and
exposed for a long time this exposure
incidentally adds up to about 10 full
days of observation the other technique
goes back to that Joe Biden image where
we look to a background Galaxy and but
we look through a foreground posture
that magnifies it and this is a
phenomenon that Einstein predicted
called gravitational lensing and it's
like um having a telephoto lens in the
sky so you look through this telephoto
lens and it provides an extra boost in
power in finding these objects
so fortunately these two very different
techniques pointing to a random area of
Sky pointing through a lensing or
magnifying cluster do give the same
result
and that is that as we go back in time
to higher and higher redshift to when
the universe was younger and younger and
younger the number of galaxies that we
see drops precipitously
for aficionados this is what we call a
logarithmic scale and there's a factor
of a thousand from top to bottom
now with Hubble we reach the end this is
as far as we could see with Hubble
because we run out of filters because of
the redshift and the stretching of light
and there was some debate in the
community
as to you know
um what's going on here if the number
drops very steeply as theorists like
then Cosmic Dawn was quite recent maybe
redshift 12 to 13 but if the number is
going more slowly then Cosmic Dawn would
be somewhere earlier in Cosmic history
this is already out of date we have made
such progress in just six months uh with
James Webb
before we turn to James Webb there is
one other trick and that is you could go
to a very distant object like this one
here
and although you can't you can't probe
back enough to see objects like it
forming if you knew how old this object
is how old the stars in this object is
it would give you an indirect way so the
analogy here is
you're walking down the street and you
meet her a boy he's four years old but
you weren't there when he was born but
if you could find out how old he is then
of course you can you can indirectly
estimate when he was born and it's
exactly the same so we went to find this
Galaxy
and we measured its redshift this is in
the Atacama Desert here you can see it's
a it's a really Barren place in in
Northern Chiles in some parts of the
Atacama Desert it's not rained in
recorded history believe it or not this
is the European very large telescope
um one of the astonishing observatories
maybe the only Euro the only large
telescope with a swimming pool I might
have had
um we measured the age of this galaxy
uh to be 290 million years so it only
formed
after 250 million years after the big
bang we repeated this experiment for six
objects and just before the launch of
Space Telescope we predicted that Cosmic
Dawn is a gradual process that occurred
between 250 and 400 million years
after the big bang
so here we are this is this monster
telescope as a human here this is in the
Northrop Grumman facility in El Segundo
in Los Angeles and I was very privileged
to see it in February 2020 one month
before lockdown
and uh you can see it's a segment what
we call a segmented mirror telescope it
has 18 segments
it's six and a half meters from top to
bottom the mirror has to be folded to be
launched each of these segments is made
of lightweight beryllium which is the
lightest metal
and is gold coated it's gold coated to
improve its reflectance uh in the
infrared
I was on the original committee
in 1996 I was the only european-based
member of that committee that proposed
uh this amazing facility where at the
time it was called the Next Generation
Space Telescope so yeah so 21 years hard
work by thousand Engineers uh with many
ups and downs you know threatened
cancellation cost overruns
but then finally
this expensive facility
is hanging here by a hawk I mean your
heart would be in your mouth if you were
there uh and it's been transferred into
the nose cone of this Ariane space
rocket in Guyana in South South America
launched on Christmas Day
2021 this is the last View
uh that we will ever have of it because
it is not orbiting the Earth like Hubble
Is orbiting the Sun in a very special
place where the gravity of the Earth and
the Sun enable it to orbit with the same
period as the earth goes around the Sun
and here's where we are I'm at the end
of the story
um
here's that controversy uh the theory
predicted that Cosmic Dawn would be
around a redshift of 12 or so we have
actually already in the space of six
months probed much deeper
to when the universe was about 300
million years old we're seeing galaxies
out to redshift 14 there have been
claims even of galaxies at redshifts are
16. what the puzzle here
is I mean I'm very pleased with this
because we predicted that would be
Starlight out here from our observations
of the ages of those galaxies but there
is an important discrepancy here
that the galaxies are much brighter than
theory predicts and we can discuss that
we don't know what it what it what what
is the cause of that
um we are getting Spectra of these
galaxies now running out of time so I'll
speed up a little bit that Galaxy the
most distant one that we saw with Hubble
I was so pleased 11.9 uh the Spectrum
confirms its redshift it's a beautiful
Spectrum
we see chemistry
there's a Galaxy and a redshift of 10
where the spectrum is so beautiful that
we see the chemical elements nitrogen
helium carbon magnesium neon oxygen and
so forth
so it is an amazing time Brian and you
know we are optimistic that we will see
Cosmic Dawn somehow whether it'll be
statistical uh or otherwise and you know
every every telescope I've used in my
career has done much more science than
it was originally intended to do and as
I often say in my talks you know unlike
politicians astronomers deliver far more
than they predicted so it is an amazing
time so I'll stop sharing my screen
shall I yes yes thank you so much
Richard that's a a real treat and a
delight for my viewers some of whom are
quite young and deciding on what career
path they may choose we have a very very
young and
be it you know fortunate or not or the
mostly male audience and and yeah any of
them are looking towards careers in the
stem fields and yeah I think this type
of presentation from one of the you know
gurus and svengalis of the field uh will
help to convince not a small number of
individuals that this is indeed perhaps
one of the most important significant
and exciting fields that one can go into
and I would only you know further
buttress that with a call to the uh the
experimentalists like me who want to
build the instruments and take part as
well as uh as The Observers in the
analysis of the data I mean the only
thing I think that we observers and and
experimentalists don't do is come up
with brand new theories but we do have
to at least my students do Richard I'm
interested in your educational
philosophy you've had 100 graduate
students or something a thousand papers
uh one of the most renowned my
philosophy of my graduate students is
that they don't need to create new
theories but they need to understand the
theory that underpins their field and
adjacent Fields what's your educational
pedagogical philosophy yeah I agree I
agree and there's a lot of um you know
if you go back to Hubble and Sandage
Hubble
was really an empiricist he had no basic
understanding of Einstein's theory he he
actually although it's claimed that he
discovered the expanding Universe he he
never said he did uh he never claimed
the universe was expanding and he was
reluctant to learn the theory and uh
Sandage who is in many ways my hero uh
changed his philosophy and said I must
understand the mathematics of Einstein's
ex model of the universe if I'm to be a
successful Observer and in my career you
know we we've we now have a model of the
universe it's called the cold Dark
Matter model uh it postulates that much
of the gravitating material in the
universe is dark and I've had to learn
from uh theorists like Carlos Frank who
was at Durham with me for many years the
fundamental aspects of that theory so I
agree you know just uh going out to the
night sky and looked and being inspired
isn't enough it really helps to have the
physical basis of what people are saying
and that's why of course we go to
Scientific meetings yeah that's right
yeah and but also to capture for the
professional Set uh I I've been
astonished through my career at how the
paucity of basic astronomical knowledge
is amongst my astronomical colleagues
even The Observers I'll have them over
you know we'll uh we'll be talking in
the night and maybe having a drink or
something and I'll say oh look up there
what do you they're like don't ask me
what that is I'm astronomer and I'll say
oh yeah I guess when we go to the
geography department and I ask where's
Mexico they'll say ah don't ask me I'm a
political
scientists are uh but but for me it's
it's the it's this visceral connection
that you can do it anytime anywhere I've
been to the South Pole uh not at night
uh because I'm not that insane but I've
been there during the day at the South
Pole which lasts six months obviously
and and the only astronomical object you
can see is the Moon but you can see it
and the Sun but that's about it and yet
you could still do astronomy anywhere on
Earth any time of year and to me it's
it's been the constant companion for my
intellect throughout for the last you
know uh four decades or so but I want to
ask you in the book you talk briefly
about uh Fred Hoyle he was of course a
very close collaborator with Willie
Fowler
um who uh you know was was probably you
I don't know did you over you didn't
overlap with him dude I did I never met
with his Fowler but I lived in his house
in Pasadena believe us yeah I already
found this out by accident yeah but
anyway yeah so the burbages Jeff and
Margaret Burbage Titanic uh contributors
to astronomical discoveries throughout
the 20th century the mentors severe
Ruben and her first exploits into
spectroscopy and later go on to uh
rotation curves taught by them really uh
and even Jeff was it was a theorist but
he never you know I knew him very well I
miss him greatly he was irascible and
every time we'd have a cosmologist come
to speak the moment that person would
mention whether it was my colleague
asantha Kure or Adrian Lee these are
renowned professors in the UC system
they'd come down and Jeff would sit in
the front row he was this jovial large
you know big British Lion and uh
Margaret was the opposite she would
never talk she was so sweet and so quiet
but she I I don't think I ever exchanged
five words with her in my in her own you
know overlap but anyway Jeff would
harump and he would say cosmology really
really uh and yet he would be very
patient he wouldn't like you know dress
down the speaker but it's clear he
always believed in the falsity of the
Big Bang model until he died and uh so
much so that his colleague and Fred
hoyle's one of his best graduate
students giant narlacar who's been a
guest on this podcast if you can believe
it
um he you know still maintains in the
veracity of the quasi-steady state what
do you do with people like that or now
the latest controversy is the Big Bang
never happened and that's proven by the
rotation of spiral galaxies and their
observation at redshift you know 10 11
12 and that's impossible therefore the
Big Bang how do you deal with otherwise
you know intellectually
yeah you have to have an open mind
um you know there's I know the young
people and I've seen you know the the
easily uh you know drawn Along by
standard the standard Theory and there
it's very popular for young people to
ridicule some old eccentric who's you
know believes that we live in a steady
state universe or that the Big Bang
model is incorrect or so and often at
conferences you know somebody will stand
up and and make a case for some exotic
model of the universe and the young
people often you know uh you know roll
their eyes and you know put their heads
in there down and so forth but I think
as scientists
we have to be professional and we have
to listen and we have to engage in these
people so
um you know I have met nalaka and of
course Fred Hoyle as well I'm at Fred
Hoyle
um because he was a previous uh premium
professor in Cambridge and you you've
got to give them the the moment their
moment to ask these questions and the
reason for that is occasionally but very
rarely there's some truth uh in these
crazy ideas and the moment you stifle
crazy ideas
um then creativity is lost
well Richard you've been so gracious
with your time your materials you've
helped us look through a crystal ball
into the future of where astronomy is
going but now I want to ask you one of
my uh four patented questions that I ask
all my esteemed guests when they come on
the podcast or all four of them are
related in one sense or another to the
uh great Sir Arthur C Clarke another
country and who gave us the is the
namesake of the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination of which I am the
associate director here at UC San Diego
and he said many things and and uh one
of them is is quite famous we open the
audio podcast with his actual voice
saying the following he's saying any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable for magic I want to
ask you if you were to think about what
the most magical technology ever
invented by a human brain and a human
culture what would you say it is
in the whole of History
I would say the wheel
okay very good
um
not the filter wheel right right the
wheel the wheel obviously you begin with
the wheel with carrying heavy things uh
and in leading to Mobility but the wheel
then becomes and then you know an
engineer's Tool uh for lifting things
and ultimately you know for um for the
motor vehicle
um and transport and airplanes and
everything you know so you know it's the
one thing and now it's uh it's a
functional thing it's not something that
improves health or you know but so but
it's a difficult Choice that's your next
question yeah the next question is
another uh quote from uh Sir Sir Arthur
C Clarke and that is the following when
an elderly but distinguished scientist
says something is possible he she is
very probably right when he or she says
something is impossible he is most
certainly wrong what have you been wrong
about if anything over your career yeah
um well often we claim that these
galaxies are at these extreme distances
and the literature is riddled with
mistake with mistaken objects an object
that people got excited about as the
most distant Galaxy uh and I'm not you
you know I'm I want to emphasize that
I'm just like everybody else I've fallen
into that trap too and so in your own
sometimes in your own enthusiasm to make
a discovery you can
say that something is believable when
it's marginal so um the way we talk
about this in science is the
significance of an observation if an
observation is noisy uh but you you feel
that you know in your heart that the
observation is exciting then it's
possible to write a scientific paper
where you say well I'm not 100 sure this
is correct but if it is correct uh it's
a revolution in the subject and there's
many ways in which you can write such
papers and I've been guilty of doing
that just like everybody else yes it's
it's almost reminds me of What's called
the banister effect where Roger
Bannister was the first to break the uh
the four minute mile in a mile and then
everyone after that has done it you know
and so it's like well what if we you
know raise the age by one more year do
we get you know to write a famous paper
it's kind of like pharaohs would be
buried with all their treasure I guess
we all human beings want to have a mark
of Our Own Richard the last question has
to do not with uh looking uh forward
through a crystal ball through this type
of lens but looking through one of these
lenses and looking into the past as you
said telescopes are time machines owing
to the finite nature of the speed of
light we're talking now we have a little
bit of a delay between LA and San Diego
we hear voices on the moon we see images
from the from Hubble and from the James
Webb these are delayed I want to ask you
a question as uh Sir Arthur said he said
uh the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible and that's the
name of the origin of the name of this
podcast I want to ask you as well rich I
want to ask you looking back through a
telescope of time what mysterious aspect
of your life your career baffled you and
what advice would you sort of give to
that 20 year old self in order to give
him the courage to do as you have done
to go into the impossible
well I think in my I I lived in a very
interesting time where there was
adequate funding firstly for bigger
telescopes
um technology went through a revolution
um the digital detector the the robots
that I mentioned making bigger mirrors
out of segments rather than trying to
make single glass mirrors
um so technology
is the advance and I think when you
um
you know I also and as I discuss in my
book I actually raise money for these
technological developments so I would
keep my eye open
for an interesting new twist in
technology and I would think gosh this
would really transform uh astronomy so I
think just plodding along and using the
same telescope you know and trying to do
better work with the existing equipment
is Never Enough you have to be
interested in the instruments themselves
and not most astronomers are not you'd
be surprised most astronomers regardless
like going to the going to the
supermarket they say what's available
I'll go in there oh I can use this I can
do that what about designing your own
Supermarket you know and that's you know
I'm proud that that's what I did I
managed to couple my enthusiasm with an
interest in technology even if I wasn't
an engineer myself I would I would find
an engineer and I would say look if you
work with me we really make discoveries
if we can do it this way and and I
that's the feature of my book as well
the partnership with technology yeah I
love the aspect of it that's uh it's a
memoir it's not only an elucidation of
the most fascinating in my humble
opinion uh branch of all of science you
know Richard it's I pointed out in the
first class that I gave in my cosmology
physics 162 uh here at UC San Diego a
couple of weeks back and a greetings to
all my students I'll see you soon as I
will begin teaching soon uh the the
Wikipedia entry for all of science if
you go to Wikipedia and type in science
I'll leave this as a homework exercise
for the reader and Watcher and type in
signs you will see a picture of no other
branch of science other than what
Richard and I have been discussing for
the last hour and that's a testimony to
how important and both historically and
for the present and future development
of not only ideas but also technology so
uh Richard Ellis uh phenomenal uh
discussion wonderful book
congratulations on both I wish you uh
safe travels back to the UK and I hope
to meet you in person one day over there
or over here
thank you very much Brian it's been a
pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]